there are many tales of people achieving
all sorts of fortune and fame by selling
their souls to the devil blues guitarist
Robert Johnson is probably the most
famous subject of that tall tale the
legend goes that he offered his soul at
a Mississippi Delta crossroads and in
return he'd receive musical success and
talents beyond his wildest dreams and
yes to this day he is considered a
pioneer of American blues guitar and
songwriting
but the devil is in the details and with
a life so shrouded in mystery it's hard
to separate fact from his very appealing
fiction Robert Johnson was born in
Hazlehurst Mississippi on the 8th of May
1911 spending much of his beginnings on
a plantation in the Delta his mother
Julia mayor Dodds was a daughter of
slaves Dodds had 10 children with her
husband's but Robert was born out of an
affair with a field hands named Noah
Johnson later in Roberts's Charlton
Julia remarried and moved the family to
Robinson Ville Mississippi Robert seemed
to take to music very quickly as a child
demonstrating keen musical ability both
on the jaw harp and harmonica that
interest didn't fade as he grew into his
teens as he was absent from school more
and more which his friends attributed to
him studying music in Memphis he would
also play around with a makeshift
instrument called a Diddley bow which
was a wire attached to a house that a
person could pull taut and hit with a
stick altering the pitch with the bottle
that slides along wah the early in
teenage years of Robert Johnson very
much shrouded in mystery
historians had to lean on anecdotal
tales from other musicians and friends
of his from those days which is a lot
like playing a game of telephone there
just isn't that much to go on and
Johnson's pneumatic nature made it even
harder to get a sense of his beginnings
had pester every musician he could for a
chance to share the stage or a jam
session with him many times between
other musicians sense Robert su would
take over the stage and play some songs
of his own certainly a bit of a bold
move legendary bluesman Son House knew
Robert
during these years and wasn't exactly
blown away by the young man's ability at
the time stating folks they come and say
why don't you go out and make that boy
put that thing down
he's running us crazy finally he left he
run off from his mother and father and
went over in Arkansas someplace or other
when he was 18 rather married 16 year
old Virginia Travis but tragedy struck
soon after as she died during Charles
birth rumors abounded that it was
punishment for his burgeoning musician
lifestyle but he forged ahead deciding
to dedicate his life to becoming a
bluesman he did manage to marry again in
1931 at the age of 20 though she too
died while giving birth this set him
down a very solitary path Johnson would
stay with numerous women who he would
return to from time to time but he
remained single adopting different
aliases the women he frequented mostly
didn't know about each other and he
preferred it that way he was a loner
committed to playing music at his
frequent stops on the road as his shows
he would play mostly crowd-pleasing
songs at the time including jazz and
country standards and even though he
would form strong temporary
relationships with the towns folk and
local musicians his days would be brief
and then he would move on as easily as
the breeze Sun House mentioned that
Johnson went to Arkansas for a time and
was somehow very different when he
returned to Mississippi the prevailing
thought was that Johnson at the time was
a mediocre guitar player but overnight
seemed to have gained an almost
supernatural ability at the instruments
that's where the myth came about that he
sold his soul to become a virtuoso
guitarist and songwriter pop culture has
had a long love affair with the idea of
a man selling his existence to an evil
entity for musical riches the 1986 film
crossroads had leading man Ralph Macchio
on a countrywide quest to learn about
the legends of that devilish pact and to
find a lost song that Robert Johnson
never got to show the world
oh brother where art thou saw'st the
trio of prison fugitives led by George
Clooney coming across one Tommy Johnson
who you guessed it sold his soul to
Satan to be able to play the guitar it's
a fantastic
story and that's why it's been told for
so long and in so many mediums and of
course it's fiction but why let the
truth get in the way of a good story
what's more likely is the robert johnson
practice tirelessly at home and at any
clubs that would give him an opportunity
to play and he even allegedly admitted
to people that during his time away he
had been studying with some kind of
guitar teacher but it seems like he had
taken those lessons to some sort of new
height his technique was something
almost completely new in which some of
his guitar lines mimics what the bass
parts of a piano would play in facts
many who study jazz playing noticed that
he did some kind of impressive
combination of playing slide rhythm and
bass all at the same time while also
singing playing nonstop is almost
certainly where those drops came from
[Music]
those drops came in handy as Johnson in
1931 was gaining enough traction to be
able to play lots and lots of gigs for
most of the 1930s Robert Johnson moved
from his Mississippi Delta stomping
grounds to Memphis and Arkansas busking
on street corners with his acoustic
guitar for tips one of the musicians
would offer him gigs it traveled to New
York Chicago and many other cities
around the country Johnny shines was one
of the musicians he would often share
bills with during his touring turns out
shines is one of the soul sources of
information that we have about Robert
Johnson during those years shines met
Johnson through a mysterious piano
player up in Memphis and even though the
two didn't quite hit it off eventually a
friendship was formed the two would hit
in new town and set up on opposing
street corners playing for tips they
both had a wandering spirit shines
remembered Robert was a guy who could
wake him up any time and he was ready to
go you say Robert I aerotrain let's
catch us and he wouldn't exchange no
words with you he was ready to go it
didn't make no difference we're just so
he was going every single gathering you
could imagine in the American South
where you could enjoy music Johnson and
shines would entertain at house parties
soul food dinners even coal yards and
sawmills that too could play music for
the people who were gathered there they
encountered some hairy moments at a stop
in Arkansas where shines as cousin got
into a shootin match with his
father-in-law Johnson and shine
took that as an omen and spent a few
months in the northern part of the
country near Detroit but Robert felt the
call of the Mississippi Delta deeply and
always returned back home Robert Johnson
did seek out a more permanent partner in
1936 but this was in the form of making
connections so that he could finally lay
down some music in the studio
he was eventually paired up with
producer Don law but it wasn't a
conventional studio they recorded in it
was a hotel in San Antonio regardless of
the facilities those three days of
recordings would go down as some of the
most important sessions ever in the
history of blues and rock music Johnson
recorded in the corner of one of the
rooms not because he was shy as many
music historians thought but to
concentrate the sound in one area to
maximize the sound of the guitar which
by then Johnson was quite proficient
with Terraplane blues come on in my
kitchen and kind-hearted woman blues
were some of the 16 songs that Johnson
laid down and then another session in
Dallas next year netted several more
Tunes overall the total output of Robert
Johnson's recording sessions in his life
was 29 songs but that small amount of
music influenced everyone from the
Rolling Stones to Muddy Waters to Led
Zeppelin to Fleetwood Mac almost any
artist who worked with in blues
arrangements and many who did not oh
some kind of debt of gratitude to the
bluesman Terraplane blues actually
became the modest enough hit in his own
lifetime but his legacy wouldn't grow
until long after his passing which was
imminent just a year after his Dallas
recordings Robert Johnson died in
Greenwood Mississippi no one knows the
cause but he was in there twenty-seven
years old at the time the public and the
press had no idea he had passed away and
it wasn't until 30 years later that a
historian happened upon his death
certificate he was simply found on the
side of a country road with no potential
motives or reasons for his passing some
say it was a jealous husband who
murdered him after Johnson flirted with
his wife other accounts say that he was
poisoned in more recent years some
medical professionals have floated the
theory that it could have been syphilis
in fact the back of his death
certificate had a handwritten note
stating the diseases his cause of death
which with his proclivity for women
wouldn't be far out of the realm of
possibility but like so much of his
legends no one really knows how to fill
in the gaps and no one really knows
where he is buried the timing of his
death could not have been worse
Johnson was just about to be showcased
at Carnegie Hall for a monumental
tribute concert his mega success so far
with his songs would undoubtedly of
skyrocketed after such a high-profile
event prominent Columbia Records
executive John Hammond said Johnson in
mind specifically to lend his talents to
the event but well sadly it was not to
be our onic Lee
decades later John Hammonds would put
together the album reissue of Robert
Johnson's songs that would finally make
him a household name as the father of
music blues 1961 's king of the Delta
blues singers might not have made the
splash that I did without some
serendipitous events but Hammonds took
one of those freshly pressed LPS in 1961
and handed it to Bob Dylan Dylan was
immediately enthralled and even featured
the cover of Johnson's record on one of
his own album covers soon later
Johnson's album would be the barometer
of how hip somebody was in the 1960s
Eric Clapton would take the torch and
run with it to playing some of his music
and cream and then devoting an entire
album to Johnson later in his career
strangely if white rock musicians hadn't
copped many of his songs when rock music
was exploding in the 1960s we may never
have heard of Robert Johnson again it
cannot be overstated
just how unknown Robert Johnson was at
the time of his death and for long after
outside of serious music collectors not
only was no one really aware of how he
died or where he was buried but most
people didn't even know that he was a
thing until the 1960s Robert Johnson was
on very few people's radar as far as his
talents and the things he contributed to
the musical world was concerned in the
1990s Johnson's legacy received another
shot in the arm with the release of the
complete recordings the reissue sold a
few million copies and won a Grammy
Award for best historical record shining
a light on his
Sherman's all over again some artists
wish they could build a body of work
over decades releasing album after album
of consistent material Robert Johnson
did that interest to recording sessions
it was a couple of days worth of work
that would change guitar music in a way
that's not really credited properly the
fact that he also had the devil story
about him selling his soul only enhances
his Methos it's like creepy icing on the
cake but in no way it diminishes the
quality and urgency of his music that is
plenty devilish by itself so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below do not forget to subscribe
for brand new videos just like there's a
couple of times a week and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]